know that never stand
special now lower
forest
you know how I feel about what happened
to your family
you campaign
forest is enormous house
million to the king
army is unknown and sordid history of
hostility between
horses House Mountains loyal the white
who knows with that
in my family was suffering from the 29th
he can handle runs
doesn't scare
be on time the only way to sell
lenses with I am steam you June
half
both of them will be increased
Nash way
mine
maze is love home
the youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my break down the new telltale
footage for Game of Thrones member
the game is being released tonight admin
night occurred to you a copy the game
every week until we find something
better to give away
so are you do tend to that'd be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
it picks up right after season three
that's why we hear ramzi both and being
call Ramsey snow
ruse Boldon didn't legitimize him till
season for the show
I seen this game is opposed to span to
season 5 so we will see season four
stuff in future episodes in the game
when they release it next year
rumored to be six episodes total this
wonderful portrait
is our protagonist house Forster
starting on the left with little roll
call
this is Asher Forster x-outs I'm
currently living in so's
might be fighting with the golden
company since they're barely notable for
employing disgrace Lords from West rose
as well as noble born bastards
to the right is Talia Forster she's the
second eldest daughter
fairly musically inclined next to her is
her twin
eat in Forster I'm gonna go ahead and
say they're probably not getting down on
the twenty says
like Jamie insurgency slightly less
creepy twins
but they're both very musically inclined
is also listed as being very academic so
be given is having a lot it's here in NM
very bookish but very well-read
into the right is the eldest daughter
mira Forster she is currently when it
Marjorie tyrell
handmaidens down in King's Landing next
to her is her mother Lady Elizabeth
Forster she's my house bring feel that
she's being described as like a cross
between Santa
in Catelyn Stark into the right is Ryan
Forster
youngest to the house there's not really
a lot less than about him then to the
right
is the Lord in the house or greater
Forster you like our net stark
hopefully he will not also get his head
chopped off and then finally the last
one to the right
is Roderick Forster his older son
basically the Robb Stark
prominent military background very
proper in truth his family
unlike his younger brother who was
exiled snowing its better shot the
King's Landing
as relates to the game when I can spend
a whole lotta time here in the game play
like mostly takes place up in deep would
not
but like I said there eldest daughter is
a handmade into margarine
so Marjorie get involved with their
cause sir seatback -inc:
their chief rivals house white male just
explain the relationships
house might heal is sworn to house both
then
obviously now we know they're kinda
creepy fairly
antagonistic to the stars the
protagonist house for stirred
their sworn to house Glover which is
wodehouse start but really it's like
Whitehill versus Forster and you have
like these other major houses can swing
the background
remember what little finger said
everyone in King's Landing is a liar
so Marjorie definitely playing the game
of Thrones to
although I think she is a fairly good
character compared to search the
but she has good intentions whereas sir
see really just want power
this next week with the trailer just
explains the relationship between the
White Hills
in the Foresters this group of people
these are the White Hills
here we find out how ramzi get involved
as we know
ruse both in kinda left him in charge
this person is torturing here
that's not be on or wreak everyone I
think about him he's got him in a
basement somewhere
remember this is the end a season 3 he's
been all season 3 torturing be on
season 4 kinda begins with him in the
Reaper Sona
will see a whole lotta ramsey in the
actor the place in like these voicing
the character in the game
just like the actors the place Marjorie
in the actors placer see
you know Natalie Dormer even Peter
Dinklage all voicing their characters
which is actually pretty cool so
ramsey's no gonna be kinda like the
Joker character.
you like Batman's Joker up the game so
when he says the only way to solve our
problems with iron and steel
this is actually there mastered arms his
name is willing to go or
Satyen talks about them possibly losing
their claim
on Ironwood iron which is used for
weapons
making armor is really really really
strong wooden so it is really valuable
resource
it's like the Lannisters gold mines to
them the only thing we don't know
right now is what it is that Sir C asked
them to do
presumably its fight in the war the
Vikings because it still kinda going on
I meet
the red wedding through a lot of water
on the flames but does it is the Starks
are kinda dying down the ball 10 start
to rise up
there's still a lot of battles to be
fought they'll all be explained in the
beginning of the game though
so that last brands is no line you know
the power timber do talking about the
idea of the Boltons taking control
up the Ironwood it the same deal with
what happened on the show with them
you know slowly taking control the North
that is still playing out in season five
like we're gonna see that continue into
season 5 the show
to generate %uh say that I'm really most
excited about is just having
a narrative gameofthrones game
one did kinda driven by the books in the
show
but is like side material: starter
Martin said its bid was that he did not
explore the books or was intending to
explore so it's additive
believe it is just explain the universe
just a little bit more but it is canon
presumably if it's blue successful to do
a season 2
after the six episodes they release next
year is in with The Walking Dead game
like a new season released every year
with the number episodes per year
a minister during game play tonight when
the release said I think it's around
midnight is when steam start selling it
she should be able to buy it then
you might still be able to get the
discount on it it selling for like 25
bucks
normally it's like 30 congratulations to
this week's giveaway winners
Steve's any you in a copy the game just
message me on my channel for details
what does the term contact info so I get
your copy I'll be streaming the first
couple games
on this channel on my merges the awesome
channel and they'll start moving the
gameplay
to my game channel that is culturally
streams there's links but that in the
description so
be sure to subscribe everywhere the you
wanna get videos for that if you not
subscribe here you not just read my game
channel
does the terms a bleak future episodes
usually it's like every two months or so
when they get a new episode around this
time next year's we should expect these
into the game
must have some sort of delay in
development if you do you have any
specific requests for like 2 gameplay
videos that you are the busy for the
video game
specifically please leave them in the
comments is a quick reminder
new mobile links appear if you're on
your mobile phone or on your tablet it
seems the link that I had over here
but click here for my break down at the
season by byron trailer for season 5 the
show that is
in cookie for all my other given front
bonus videos thank you so much watching
was a high five I will see you guys
tonight